what is the meaning of life what's the
meaning of this whole thing you said
ingenuity is the thing that gives you
hope
we seem to be all busy trying to help
each other trying to build a better
world why are we doing that
i would repeat something that
steve jobs has said death is
life's biggest invention
it eliminates the old and gives place to
the new
life is all about
moving forward
creating
new things
maybe
everyone is a contributor
but no one is the owner
and always creating something new
always
adding something beautiful into the
world maybe a little bit of love
hopefully
albert thank you so much it's a huge
honor that uh you will go through some
of these difficult questions with me
today and then you give your extremely
valuable time for this conversation
thank you so much for talking today
thank you for your interest and i'm
happy as i was telling you before that
i can
brag with my kids that i was in your
podcast because you're their hero you
made it i made it
thank you thank you
you